welcome to cloud on-air live webinars
from Google cloud we're hosting webinars
every Tuesday my name is Jen Bennett
technical director in the office of CTO
and I'm thrilled to be joined by John
Sobel the CEO of sight machine one of
Google Google clouds partners today
we're going to be talking about getting
manufacturing companies started on
digital transformation just as a
reminder you can ask questions anytime
on the platform and we have Googlers on
standby to answer them so let's get
started so manufacturing is going
through a revolution we hear about
industry 4.0 smart manufacturing
whatever the name might be but the
reality is the same kind of revolution
that we saw the digital revolution that
we saw in the consumer space when we
connected billions of people and devices
is the same sort of revolution that
we're going through now within the
manufacturing space and at the core of
that revolution it's really about
personalization and we're starting to
see that now come to life in
manufacturing in mass mass customization
and being able to personalize products
and services and so with that we look at
spaces like consumer where we've seen
some of the technology that evolved to
adapt and to be able to make that mass
customization affordable and so we're
going to talk a lot a little bit about
the technology but it's not just about
technology it's also about people the
process the culture and at the core of
this technology and this transformation
it's really about data and part of the
cultural shift is becoming a really
data-driven organization and being able
to leverage the data to drive
personalization and customization and so
with that I'm going to hand it over to
John to give a talk to us a little bit
more about what they're seeing in this
space and some of the technology that
you guys have built to enable
manufacturers to go on this journey of
digital transformation Thank You Jen I'm
going to share a little background about
data in the manufacturing industry and
then as Jen suggests talk a little bit
about how companies who are effectively
using it are doing so first off I think
many of our our guests will appreciate
this those of you in Maine
you know this to be true manufacturing
generates more data than any other
industry if we think of digital data as
fuel as an opportunity for insight
there's twice as much data in
manufacturing as in any other any other
category in business and as those of you
who work in factories know this is how
this is what we do this is how we make
factories work you see the picture of
the whiteboard it's incredibly
frustrating to manufacture to have so
much digital data available the data is
generated by automation by all the
controls and software that you find in a
factory and the best we've been able to
do in most places is the daily or weekly
scrum and the whiteboard session and we
do a pretty good job factories run very
well they make complicated stuff
effectively but there's so much
opportunity if we can use the data
that's being generated and that's really
the focus of the technology behind
Google Cloud and what companies like us
we're doing a little bit more landscape
here data is useful and going to be
useful in a way that really goes to the
heart of the future manufacturing we
think about the United States as a
manufacturing economy we benefited after
World War two from a temporary
aberration the great industrial
economies of the world were sidelined by
World War two Germany and Japan both
spent 30 years rebuilding their
economies and in years since China has
become the world's largest manufacturer
so there is a global contest for
manufacturing leadership and companies
and countries are investing heavily in
the next wave of innovation which is
about data and data is useful for every
level of the game at the most basic and
and the daily level the things that
manufacturers think about every day
getting visibility into your operations
into your supply chain
keeping your factories running as
planned getting efficiency and getting
control of quality these are perennial
problems that data is incredibly
effective for using and then if we think
about everything else going on robotics
3d printing sustainability data informs
all of this and at the highest level the
transformation that companies are going
through you see some of the leaders out
there
talking about manufacturing as a service
micro factories all of this depends on
having control of data you know John you
talked about data and we talked about
the volume of data but really the
problem is only getting worse because
you know as Gartner had met you had seen
about eight point four billion devices
connected in 2017 up 31 percent but
we're seeing an even larger growth
coming in the future by 2020 right the
20 billion device is something on the
order of that so this data that you're
talking about is only getting bigger
you're right Jen I'm looking in the
rearview mirror and the problems only
gonna get worse and so we need to use
this data in contrast to other
categories you see things like smart
cities everyone talks about we got a
sensor of the cities there was already
plenty of data in manufacturing and
there's a really interesting dynamic
going on right now a couple of years ago
the the real question on people's minds
was should we do this does it matter
companies have decided that they're
going to invest in digital 98% of
enterprises are investing they're doing
things they're not going as fast as they
want and and the question is why we work
with some great companies we work with a
lot of companies who are just getting
started and and we see three themes the
first is the technology it's not as easy
as everybody says the the effective use
of data requires some real technical
chops and so you need partners like
Google and some of the great emerging
companies out there to use the data
that's a solvable problem
the the companies that serve
manufacturers are themselves trying to
figure out how to get good at this so
you got to figure out the business
landscape and then perhaps the most
important variable is the clients
themselves the organizations working
with data involves change and and the
most important thing is operationalizing
this technology getting getting new ways
of working into your workflow and that's
where companies are either succeeding or
failing it's all about the organization
here's some here's some interesting
statistics on how long companies are
spending piloting this is from the World
Economic Forum and McKinsey more than
80% of companies that are doing pilots
are spending a year or more
and in 1/4 cases are spending two years
just to pilot technologies meanwhile the
companies that are going fast or going
really fast and the gap between the
leaders and laggards is is getting wider
to give you a sense of the scale we work
with a lot of enterprise manufacturers
they're targeting a hundred million
dollars a year plus impact this is uh
this is something that can really make a
difference if you do it well and one
things we'll talk about is how to do
that how to be effective at this no one
could question are you suggesting that
pilots aren't important no sorry
pilots are important they're important
as a way to get started and you and I
both know no manufacturers just gonna go
to scale right away they got to try
something but there's a difference
between just trying stuff to try it and
trying stuff with a purpose and a plan
and what the really effective partners
are insisting on is that when you sit
down and plan out a program you get
everybody around the table operations
leaders IT leadership corporate
leadership and and talk about when this
succeeds or when we learn something what
are we going to do how we're going to
scale it yeah I think that's a really
good point I mean what we've seen as
well is that you know it's not just
about technology for technology it's
about technology solving a really key
business problem so it's one of the
great things about the manufacturing
industry our company is a bunch of
webhead to grow up in the Midwest and
most of us worked in manufacturing
growing up so we appreciate both worlds
the great thing about manufacturing for
for a technology company is it's a
skeptical practical industry it's about
results it's about measuring things and
getting things done so you got to start
with what are we gonna fix what are we
gonna help make better and then we're
back to the tech here's the technology
problem and I'll set this up really
quickly big data is often said to mean
the three V's volume velocity and
variety your companies have limitless
amount of computing power you can handle
any volume of data any velocity of
calculation but the variety is the
killer problem in manufacturing maybe
the most varied data environment that we
find anywhere this is an example of the
kinds of equipment you find inside of a
factory and it's just a thin slice of
what's out there there's literally
thousands of data sources admitting
different kinds of data multiple times a
second all the time companies have done
the hard work of getting it aggregated
getting it in a lake but now we got to
figure out how to use it that's really
the challenge one of the paradigms that
we all go to when we think about this
problem is the software paradigm we all
say oh you know I must need some new
software to do this that probably means
I gotta rewire my factory I got to
change everything that's the last thing
a good manufacturer wants to do they've
spent decades think about how hard it is
to make a car you spend decades getting
things dialed in and the last thing you
wanna do is go change the control
software or the software that that
you've relied upon good news this is not
really a software problem this is a data
problem data is ones and zeros it
doesn't care where it was generated and
it doesn't really matter what what
created the data what matters is getting
the data out and using it and with the
advent of technologies like AR and cloud
it's a data paradigm so what we need to
do to help manufacturers is get the
zeros and ones out and then put them to
work with great tools that can help us
make sense of them if you do that well
and is this is very different if we go
back for a minute the left sides of
software paradigm it's an application
paradigm so everybody goes I need an
application and understands this problem
but data when used correctly is
effective for all kinds of problems even
ones we haven't thought of so far so if
you think of the modern manufacturing
enterprise data is useful for everybody
from the Machine operator who's trying
to figure out how to make things work
better during their shift all the way up
to corporate leadership we see a lot of
companies bringing on data scientist
they're working with process engineers
something as simple as evening out to
flow in a line getting rid of
bottlenecks a couple percentage point
improvement it drops right to the bottom
line for an enterprise manufacturer
we're talking about hundreds of millions
of dollars a year just from using our
data better before you move on can you
talk a little bit about you know you've
talked about these different roles and
some are on the IT side and some are on
the OT side maybe you can give our
audience a little bit of idea about what
you're seeing in this I mean we talked
about the convergence of itno team
particularly manufacturing and around
data and making data you know
ubiquitous and giving you know giving
access to data in places maybe where
they didn't have it before give me a
little bit of sense of what you're
seeing in this IT OT convergence there's
a lot to say about that I'll try to be
brief IT for many years has served the
carpet the business processes the front
part of the operation and then there's
been this kind of interesting gray area
of the concrete there's often
connectivity on the plant floor and
there's a ton of data but it hasn't
really been thought of as the domain of
IT so it's a bit of a jump ball who
really should govern and figure out how
to use data on the plant floor and so I
tee and ot teams are starting to work
together and it's and they come at it
from very different perspectives IT
leadership has often been focused on
security and control and having a
reliable network an Operations
leadership is focused on getting more
product out the door faster and good
companies are figuring out how to put
these teams together a lot of IT
leadership is really starting to focus
on how to drive the needle and be
helpful to the business in ways that IT
has never really been called upon to do
before an Operations leadership is
starting to learn about technology it is
very much a work in progress we see all
flavors of this we see some companies
where IT leadership is really pushing
hard for change we see some companies
where operations leaders are basically
saying to their IT colleagues hey if you
don't get this going for me I'm gonna
get it going myself I need to do this
and so it's a it's gonna be figured out
over the next couple years it's
interesting yeah we talked a lot in
Google around this idea of data
democratization and now even in in
machine learning democratization but but
what we've seen with some of the
manufacturers who've really adopted this
idea of data of democratizing data is
that people who it was very difficult
engineers who was difficult to get data
from the shop floor before are now
starting to be able to get that data and
make better decisions in their role
right because of that that bringing in
that variety of data to solve problems
customer service has been able to get
better better data from you know from
service side of it or from
from the manufactory site so I think you
know some of these you know this
technology is evolving to a place where
now we can make this data available to
all rolls and help them improve what
they do with that with that availability
of data well this is why the cloud is so
important the let's just talk about all
the all the kind of functions you just
listed everything in a manufacturing
enterprise from design engineering
production the performance of products
out in the field
customer service finance sales and
marketing zeros and ones with all of it
and companies want to understand all
that together and now let's zoom out
even one step further let's talk about
the supply chain why should the
boundaries of the firm be the boundaries
of the data we look at it's all zeros
and ones and if we do this well we can
serve these stakeholders and then
everybody else who might want to use the
data and I agree with you this is a
strategic asset this is not a
traditional IT problem this is a
strategic capability if you can use your
data well you got a real edge I'll give
an example of a company we started
working with three or four years ago
that's thinking exactly this way and it
was a real opportunity for us as a young
company we had been working with some
great automotive manufacturers who were
very focused on what to do in the plant
this company came to us and said we've
got five contract manufacturers
scattered all across Asia each one's got
their own IT environment there's a bunch
of automation in each of these
facilities can you go wire up this
automation slurp off the data multiple
times a second and give us visibility
into everything happening in this supply
chain and and we've done that for them
and others and this is how companies of
the future are going to think about data
this is a route system into their
production there are their contract
manufacturers get a view of what they do
the OEM gets a view of everybody and
everybody can be better because they can
see what's going on some other examples
we get asked all the time yeah how's
this practical what does it do for me we
recently finished working in a very
large dairy one of the world's largest
dairy companies they make they make
cheese and there's an artisanal aspect
to the production of cheese that
requires
you know when to turn things on and off
in a very complicated process it's the
same as if you're making chemicals or
oil there's a lot of wisdom and tribal
knowledge about how to do this and
thousands of parameters that have to be
studied if you can know exactly when to
do something because the data tells you
that's immediate impact on the bottom
line and this company expects to realize
10 or 15 percent improvement and the
profitability of this production just
because it's using its data we've done
some work recently with huge amounts of
robots one of the largest auto plants in
North America has 300 robots assembling
cars
the robots generate a ton of data and if
they go down and they go down more than
you would expect it cost real money so
being able to know when's that can
happen how do we how do we stop it how
do we fix it the data is all there if we
can use it we can get control of these
problems and you've given us some
examples of some pretty large
manufacturing and and you know can often
be very expensive to to do these types
of projects I'm wondering and I firmly
believe that this is not just for the
large enterprises you know the the
technology has evolved to a space where
it's accessible so not only do we have
democratization it's accessible to small
to medium maybe you can give us a little
bit of insight of that as well
absolutely so a couple comments there we
have some terms we use inside our
company to describe the fastest movers
and we talked about gazelles they're
often not the largest companies there
they're nimble they want it they want it
they want to use their data and they
want to go fast and you're absolutely
right this isn't just a game for the
biggest companies the other thing is
that technology really has been
democratized now we can spin up an app
and map data to it and show you
visibility into your machines in
literally an hour or less that
technology is proliferating and just to
throw around a few stats there's over a
million factories in the United States
more than a million in China more than a
million in your very healthy percentage
of those are owned by small and
medium-sized enterprises and the
technology to do this is available for
every company on that spectrum we we
spent a lot of time studying the
organizations we were
with and I just wanted to call this out
in case you're interested in in
assessing your company there's a lot of
talk about readiness and it's really
interesting we go to companies and one
of the things we've learned to do when
you bring new technology into an
organization it's important to think
about how are we going to succeed at
this where should we start and we
learned early on this was an unexpected
insight that even within the same
company every plant is very different
and so you have widely varying levels of
readiness within the same organization
you'll see on this chart there's a kink
to the left on the y-axis is
organizational readiness the x-axis is
technical readiness to our surprise what
we learned was the very best plants were
led with the right mindset they had a
focus on data they valued data it didn't
really matter what their technical
readiness was as much as the mindset of
the organization and the leadership and
one of the best plants we ever went into
was running on Excel they're running on
Excel but they understood the value of
data and so we developed over a period
of years and based on going into
hundreds of plants an index that helps
you score where your plants are and and
where to start and if there's one
take-home point it's pick situations we
talked about pilots and getting things
going pick situations where there's some
committed leadership at the right levels
you want there's so many people in
companies have great idea the tradition
of quality of walking the gemba is that
people in the plant know more than
anybody else about what to do and how to
make it better
so tap into that wisdom and knowledge
make sure you have plant leadership
aligned and then strong corporate
leadership is so important to knock down
roadblocks and support people there's
all kinds of other interesting cultural
things we might talk about transparency
is can be wonderful if an organization
really wants to understand what it does
well and what it can be better at
transparency is incredibly powerful
there are some organizations that
struggle with transparency and so you
have to really think about where's the
right place to start how do we support
people when they find problems we didn't
know we had and how
fix them and that leads to kind of you
know a list of best practices there's a
lot of words on the slide I'll try to
distill the key ones we talked about
pilots with a focus on getting to
operational making operational use the
acid test is something that good
companies do right away it's one thing
to try technology just to experiment but
we got to get going here and so thinking
about when this works or when we learn
something what are we going to do to go
to scale separates companies that are
succeeding from from others this is a
change exercise we've seen a few
companies another bullet point here is
about embracing change as a discipline
in itself I was shocked we went to a
plant recently in Australia and somebody
introduced herself and said I'm the
change leader here I asked her what's
your job she said I was hired to help
the technology people talk to the
operations people and I've seen this now
in two or three companies in the last
couple months companies are actually
thinking about how do we bring this into
our operations how do we get people
talking to each other and have
designated change leaders you know I
think that's really interesting if you
think about lean manufacturing it really
is the foundation of agile software
practices and yet we've kind of gotten
away from this idea of adaptability I
know you and I have talked about this
quite a bit but the world is changing
faster than even our manufacturing
plants can adapt and so this idea of
adaptability and agility is going to be
more important now than ever and really
if you take it you're your core
foundation the ability to to automate
the processing of data and bringing
together all that variety of data to
help make better decision process to
support the decision-making processes
you you enable agility in ways that
really truly allow growth I'm so glad
you said that the the notion of
continuous improvement which is the soul
of great manufacturing is exactly the
same idea as using data to get better
and great manufacturers think about
getting a little bit better every day
and and just like lean this is another
this is another tool in the toolkit for
doing it it's powerful it's powerful
because once you get that foundation set
you can do so much more beyond it but we
can call upon we don't have to change
the soul of manufacturing this is what
manufacturers do already they think how
do I get better every day the other
thing I would suggest is have a big bold
vision go big and fast don't do
everything up front but be thinking
about more than just production be
thinking about the links between
production data and everything else in
your organization and last and we call
this out as a kind of a special bullet
point partnering this is a common
distracted at the really large companies
I think a lot of manufacturers partner
very well if you think about how good
supply chains work those are those are
essentially partnerships but some very
large manufacturers are accustomed to
working with kind of a monopoly position
in their industry I was speaking with a
CIO last week and I think he paid us the
greatest compliment and in a way said
the greatest thing about his company he
could have said we're talking about
working together and I said hey can I
come see you when can I get on your
counter and he said listen you come down
here whenever you want you're not a
vendor you're a partner I'm trying to
change our company and the way I'm gonna
do that is with partners that truly is a
mindset if we think about how
procurement works and all the stuff that
we do in large companies they're not
built with a partnership mindset they're
built with efficiency and they're built
to serve the organization when we're
talking about change and using data and
bringing in technology it's gonna be
through partnership and companies that
are good at partnering and one things I
admire so much about Google is Google
really does partner with companies you
all have thought about changing so many
industries that you you bring that
sensibility to the table and those
manufacturers that are doing this well
are definitely thinking that way as well
so those are those are some some
learnings we ought to just take it from
there one quick question or thought that
I had - we talked about data and you
talked about the fact that people can
handle large volumes of data but what we
find in practice is that people are
handling them - spreadsheets right and
through notebooks and through word of
mouth and and that's
really how you handle big data tell us a
little bit about some of the I am super
excited about the technology that we
offer but I'm even more excited in some
ways about some of the secret sauce that
you have can you give us a little bit of
insight into some of the secret sauce
absolutely I appreciate the question I
didn't want to dive too too deep into
what we do or into the tech but but
here's what's been missing if it were
easy to do this this would have been
done already because companies have been
wrestling with spreadsheets and data
lakes and data for four years what's
been missing is what we call a canonical
data model a systematic way to drop into
any manufacturing environment and make
sense of that data through an automated
data model and you need a model that can
handle different environments you can't
just build a model for a car plant
because then you can understand part of
a car plant but you can't go to
electronics plant so you actually need
to model manufacturing as a discipline
bake that smart into your data model and
then what you find and so this was our
journey we started working in a bunch of
plants around the world and they all
made different things and we needed a
way to understand it so we built
abstracted data models and kept refining
and improving them through experience
and then we had a pipe in a huge amount
of data our company takes in about 15
billion data points a week right now for
our clients and that's a fraction of
what we'll do in a couple years and you
need software automation to put all that
data in the right place and they use
machine learning and classification
techniques to kind of understand it so
basically having a representation of
what happens in a factory built into
math and software so you can get
empirical and we kind of done this 10
years ago if you think of all the
different data types there's time series
data there's a there's alarms or stuff
in Excel there's text there's pictures
we now have the technologies that allow
us to bundle and attach all those data
points to these models and so that's
what's been needed and if you put that
in kind of the middle of everything and
then you have you extract the data put
it through that engine and then most
important find relationships that matter
to a business person like we don't just
want to give people a bunch of tools and
say play with the data we want to take
it - hey the machines down why or
something bad happened and cause bad
quality what's different
in the system for bad parts and good
parts or I got a recall do I need to
recall everything or just things that
were made last Thursday the answers are
there in the data if we can use it you
talked a little bit throughout this
about the cultural change and the
leadership and how that can really help
enable us but I'm guessing a lot of our
viewers may not be the CEO of their
companies maybe give us a little bit of
insight of like if you know how
everybody in their role can can really
take take advantage of this and
leverages how is this applicable to
yours sure
so I think it's an important question
because one of the comments we had
earlier on one of our slides is the
importance of leadership company
leadership that embraces this is
critical I really appreciate Jen's
question because not every leadership
team is necessarily embraced so what do
you do if you're in an organization and
you want to start you want to start
making progress with your data how do
you do it and I think that's the
majority of organizations today so a
couple comments first pick something
that you can get started with and go
fast and it's amazing how once a screen
pops up and there's some evidence that
you can see something that you can see
before we used to joke about in our
earliest days we started working in a
big automotive plant the Train we call
the factory TV as soon as there was a
picture up and people could see what was
going on they got excited so you got to
initiate that empowered yeah yeah
exactly and they they they could make a
difference so you got to initiate the
change I think that speaking very
bluntly fear works really well letting
your leadership team know you're falling
behind you're falling behind as a
management team here's what other
companies in our you don't say it that
way but here's what other companies in
our industry are doing and here's where
we're gonna be if we don't keep up is
effective and then I think so much of
this is cross-functional
so finding champions you and I had an
interesting conversation before we
started today about command and control
and how increasingly organizations Jamie
Dimon just wrote a great shareholder
letter JP Morgan CEO said bureaucracy is
a disease they need to get rid of it
it's amazing large companies are
realizing that
innovate we got to open up the channels
and if you're if you're somebody who
wants to make change happen find allies
find people who are influential pick a
project that that is within your budget
get it you know light a spark and
hopefully people will pile on and you
know I also think this whole idea of
democratization of data making data
available if as though as a leader
that's a choice you can make pretty
easily making data available and then
what we've seen even within our own you
know operations so we run data centers
you know when we have and we're a
data-driven organization anyways but
we've had you know data availability we
had engineers who took the data and
built machine learning models and now
our data centers you know in the summer
can are running 40% more efficiently 40%
like I'm talking to manufacturers now
where every single percentage point is
large amounts of money right so 40% when
you make data available and empower the
individuals within the organization so I
think this is really we have to
continuously champion you know the
return on investment that we see just by
making data readily available and as you
said the secret sauce is making it
usable as well so I think that's really
important I think we have a couple just
a couple more minutes before we're going
to start the live Q&A so maybe one of
the things I wanted to talk about we
talk a lot about analytics and there's
many many companies out there who are
doing analytics why do we still lack
this basic visibility when these tools
are available in analytics are readily
about what is it that is is causing this
this problem so analytics is one of
those words it's a tough word I think
you're actually right you asked me a few
minutes ago what's the what's the secret
sauce to making data useful if we can't
put data in the right building blocks we
can't do the math we need to do on top
of things if I try to understand a bunch
of time series data points and then
relate that to thousands of other things
I'm not gonna get anywhere and so let's
think of analytics is math there's no
secret math to understand a factory we
can use a lot of good statistical
techniques and machine learning
techniques on top of data there's
probably hundreds of companies out there
right now and we
in some form or another about analytics
but I'll tell you what's been really
interesting in our journey the the
customers are smart manufacturers have
been working with statistics and with
data for many years and they know
whether or not something can analyze
their data and so we try to stay away
from kind of the software industry terms
for this because they are so unhelpful
what's really needed is I mean here's
the acid test for those of you who are
gonna try stuff just just demand that
the company is working with you get you
an answer fast and that they do it
scalable and and stay away from what you
call it you'll know very quickly whether
or not you can find patterns and
relationships in your data or not yeah I
mean I think that's a really great point
one of the reasons why I'm super excited
about sight machine and the partnership
with Google is I mean I worked with you
earlier on and in my career and and
through a couple of very different
problems to test that to do that as a
test to say you know the real problem is
not going in in automating a line or in
gathering data from one plant it's
really about that problem around can you
really get it across multiple and and
across different problems without you
know in a cost-effective way
because truly that's what that's the
growth that we're seeing the agility
that we need that adaptability isn't
developing software to solve one
specific problem it's really that secret
sauce that you have to be able to build
that model to allow people to use data
in new ways and solve new problems with
that same data and I think we're seeing
this across a number of manufacturers
and and really just want to make sure
that people are aware that these
technologies exist and and they're very
fruitful when applied and I think the
last point is is that yeah visibility is
crucial in it that data is the is the
first step in that journey right getting
data visible you walked us through that
really nicely visibility solving some of
those key problems around quality you
know and then moving up into the point
at which you can start to use machine
learning but honestly when we talk about
machine learning if you're not
collecting and data and getting it
aggregating in a way that can be
meaningful machine learning is not going
to help you
right right you need to you need to take
these steps to get data
and and so that that's really key John
it's been really great we're gonna go
and start our Q&A so stay tuned we'll be
back in about a minute
you
so thanks for joining us and we have
some really great questions really
excited so let's get started first of
all John the first question that came in
what is the technical insight behind the
sight machine solution is it just
advanced ETL for manufacturing so can
you give us a little bit of I love this
insider game somebody who knows what
they're doing here so yeah the question
is is it an advanced ETL short answer is
yes and I think I'm not an engineer so I
want to be careful not to get out over
my skis too much here but it's a unified
way of doing ETL on the fly for the
manufacturing environment so instead of
having to go build a new model every
time we encounter a new process or
facility we configure a very
sophisticated stack that invokes ETL
that's basically been pre-built but can
be configured for that environment
there's a lot of other pieces you need
to have or removing a lot of zeros and
ones around between edge and cloud and
all kinds of other stuff but that
question is a great question because it
goes to the heart of it which is having
a flexible abstracted data model that
serves every manufacturing environment
and I think I'll just offer this comment
for our viewers this is how we're gonna
do it in a bunch of industries the
horizontal platforms that are out there
are great for aggregating data but if
you want to understand farming or
buildings or cities or healthcare there
needs to be some smarts that's built
into the middle of the stack and that's
what this question goes to great
question mm-hm
the next question how do you
specifically get data from the wide
variety of PLC manufacturers and the
question was I understand you can make a
generic API but that doesn't actually
get the data off the PLC's and into so
this is this is another really good
technical question let's go let's zoom
up really high here three jobs to make
data useful extract it analyze it
present it somehow this is a question
about extraction and and we're
partnering with some great automation
companies we get asked this all the time
so people in the controlls environment
are used to a very rigid data structures
and the intuition that most of us have
is oh I got to work with all that stuff
inside of that actually all you need to
do is pull that data off if you can get
a digital data stream off of a PLC we
start to transform the data
once we pull it off so we just need to
get it off and and 80% of PLC's in North
America are made by the top three PLC
manufacturers so once you know how to
talk to Siemens Alan Brad well Bradley
Rockwell Allen Bradley or Mitsubishi you
got 80% of them and so it's about
extracting the data not trying to work
with inside the controls code and then
transforming it through what we do but I
think the other point that you made
which I think is really important yes
there's a lot of there's data coming off
of the machines and the PLC data there's
also a lot of other data floating around
the manufacturing shop for right that
may not be coming from a PLC and so I
think part of the the value of the site
machine solution built on Google Cloud
is really being able to handle that
variety of data it's not just time
series data off the machine and alarm
date off the machine but so I think
that's also important to keep in mind
and well said let's just hammer the
point here because it would be very
dangerous
to build a solution around one piece of
automation or one data source data is
coming off of operators it's in quality
systems it's in your automation and
controls and we've seen this wave of
solutions that's been built for data of
a certain type and the way Google thinks
about data and the way we think about
data is data is data and so we ought to
be getting a solution that's open and
agnostic and companies are very smart
about this they do not want to be locked
into XYZ companies Data Platform that
only goes with that company's equipment
that's a horrible business model for
customer great business model if you can
get away with it selling the equipment
but it's not gonna work in a factory
there's too many things so I think
you're dead on mmm-hmm great next
question what tools technology platforms
are available to specifically support
organizations and highly regulated
environments for example medical devices
pharma to really help begin this digital
transformation so highly regulated
industries are probably one of the best
places to start the the need for
traceability from end to end so if we
think about highly regulated industries
it's usually something where there is a
some risk if the product isn't built
right so drugs increasingly food medical
device all of this is production we want
to understand holistically and with a
great degree of control and granularity
there are a bunch of disparate tools out
there right now as people prepare for
increasing regulation there's a lot of
point solutions
what's needed and what I think you're
starting to see is a way to knit
together all these data sources without
having to go change historians or
various compliance techniques that
company reviews so you can think of all
these islands of tools that exist and we
need some water to connect it up and
we're there if we get the data out of
all of these islands we can do very
powerful things with it that is exactly
what a regulator wants to see a
regulator wants to know can I see how
this batch was made so that I know that
this batch is bad but the other ones are
good can I see that data you already
have all that data you know I think one
of the things I have a real passion
around this and I know you do as well
but this idea that you know not to
distance in the future we're going to be
connecting up all of these data sources
so that things like recalls I mean I
know that we will look back and say how
crazy it was that how we how we found
out about recalls right we just heard
about this cluster of you know things
that happen in a particular population
and then we takes months yeah to get to
the point where you know the
manufacturing side is just one small
piece of it as we start to really bring
together data I think these patterns
this ability to really find problems
quicker is going to be it's gonna be
game-changing in our in our in our world
I have a colleague our CMO at Jota
always talks about how when Samsung had
terrible problems with with its
batteries you get on a plane and the
first thing they'd say is don't bring
this device on the plane and the whole
world was marketing against this quality
problem unfortunately it took several
months to figure out what went wrong
what you just said is gonna change how
companies get control of these problems
and we're gonna look back one day and go
man that was the stone Age's yeah yeah
probably have one time for one more
question so we don't own many of our own
plants but use contract manufacturers
how can you drive change across the
virtual supply chain involving many part
I know you
know this really well so I mean we both
love this question because the supply
chain is really the right frame of
reference this requires some cooperation
I think good supply chains already have
trust and cooperation those supply
chains that can handle it simply need to
share data we have seen some
manufacturers in the middle the supply
chain generate huge amounts of
credibility and confidence in their
production because they share data with
their customer so our very first
customer we started our company in
Southeast Michigan our very first
customer
was bending metal selling to the big
three and realized that if they showed
data about their production and the
control over quality they had that would
be a competitive advantage in their
supply chain they were getting seven or
eight percent of the bids that they put
in and once they revealed the data they
were able to get all kinds of high value
higher margin work because they
generated trust so this is good for
everybody if you're confident in your
production share your data if you're the
head of the supply chain ask your
partner's to share it with you we can
all be better if we do it it's not easy
it's a little scary sometimes but that's
how you get good and I think too that
manufacturers have the this is something
that is becoming more and more important
as around getting that data it really is
critical and and really having you know
suppliers give giving them a preferred
supplier if they provide you know if you
have that better integration I think
these are things that I'm a business
model perspective that you can start to
look at as well one last comment real
quick there's all kinds of fights about
ownership you own your own data it's
your data we can share it we can use it
we can put up a license regime around it
this is a totally solvable problem yeah
I know we agree and you know we have one
minute actually so I'm going to take
this last one really quickly our
organization does not have many data
science resources we talk a lot about
this John
especially at plant locations how can we
better how can we drive better decision
making without these capabilities yeah
quickly jump in and say I mean from a
Google perspective we understand that
data science resources are very
difficult to get and so one of the
things that we're trying to do with our
technology as well is to provide better
tooling that enables the democratization
date of science capabilities right and
so making that more attainable but maybe
you can give us a few quick insight I
love this question we went to a plant a
year ago at a very large company they
had 200 data scientists on the line I
called up our CTO and said oh can we
help them understand anything they have
200 data scientists he said good news
they don't know anything if they have
200 data scientists you don't need that
many
and if companies like us do our job
right we're gonna give you really
helpful useful insight there's a real
range a few gets a lot done and if you
want to invest in more it's going to be
a great field so many thanks for joining
us if you're interested the phone the
next webinar is cube flow machine
learning at kubernetes machine learning
really important in manufacturing as
well so please stay tuned for that
session as well thanks for joining
you